Sáng nay, bùng năm 30 tại Hà Nội Bộ sáo dụng vào đạo tạo đạo tổ chức học báo thông tin về phân án sử lý đối với tí sình
tại nhận thí trường Trung Hoặc của Thông Trình Tuyên quan trong vị thí tốt nghiệm Trung Hoặc của Thông năm 2020
Căn cứu ghét của anh điều tra bàn đầu, bộ sáo dụng vào đạo tạo quyết định tổ chức thí lại từ cả các món
đối với tí sình tại nhận thí trường Trung Hoặc của Thông Trình Tuyên quan
vị tổ chức thí lại nhằm bảo đam yêu cầu ăn toàn, nghiệm tốt Trung thật, khách quan và công bàn của vị thí
và bảo đam các nguyên tắc yêu cầu chỉ đạo của chiếc vô. Không phải là biển pháp xử lý kỳ hội đối với tí sình tại đều thí.
Chách nghiệp của tình Tuyên Trung Trức cả nhân trong nó có thí sình vì pháp, sẽ được xem sát xử lý cần thử kết của điều tra với bất độ vì pháp buộc thế theo quy đen.
Bộ sáo dụng bởi đầu tạo đăng hình trường xây dựng kết quảy tổ chức thí lại theo đúng quy trễ thí,
bảo đam ăn toàn nghiêm tốt khách quan của bằng và tạo điều kết thật lợi nhất cho thí sình.
Khi đi lại được tụi chức trong 2 ngày dự kiến này 1 bảo 1 tảm đúng hay gần thái sấu,
cũng mù kết quả thí dự kiến vào ngày 12 tảm đúng hay gần thái sấu.
Kết quả thí ngày 1 bảo 1 ngày 12 tảm đúng hay gần thái sấu của các thí sình.
Tại diễm thí trường trường trường trường quan sẽ không được xử dụng để sét tuyện vào các trường đại học caul đăng.
Bảo các thí sình này cũng không được thăm ra sét tuyện. Theo các phíng thức pháp cho đến phí có kết quả thí lại.
Sau khi có kết quả thí lại, kết quả hợp lệ sẽ được cập nhật bảo vệ thống và sử dụng để sét tuyện theo các nguyện vọng tí sình đã đăng kí.
Hình vua ăn vấn đăng trong quá trình điều tra bộ giấu rức bởi đầu tạo sẽ tiếp tục phủ hợp cho chẽ với các cửa quan trích năng của bụi cùng ngàn và các cửa liên quan để xưa liên nghiêm các tụi chức cả nhân vi phạm.